[Musique]
bonjour marc védrines bienvenue pour
votre vie peuvent y aille pirelli noise
personnes vous êtes installé à buc
et c'est là que c'est déroulera bientôt
une nouvelle édition du festival de la
bande dessinée
c'est là que vous ouvrez vous travaillez
vous avez une histoire particulière avec
cette ville de buc non pas
particulièrement
il se trouve que de la bd rien festival
on connaissait avant avant d'y habiter
mais on n'était pas loin j'étais à
versailles donc j'avais déjà été invités
puis là le hasard fait que du coup
j'habite à 300 mètres de là où ça se
passe donc vous ne pouvez pas rater cet
évènement pas le rater quelques suées
régulièrement
voilà c'est ça l'invité un bouton après
il est né en 71,6 avez réalisé votre
première bande dessinée à l'âge de 6 ans
entourée fait ce que j'ai lu est ce que
ça fait partie de la légende ou est ce
que c'est vrai même même peut-être même
avant il se trouve que quand on est
auteur de bd que on aime le dessin on
aime aussi raconter des histoires et
puis je dirais pas c'est une vocation
comme un médecin mais mais pas loin quoi
on a envie de on a envie de partager ça
avec les autres c'est vraiment la bd ça
ce but là mais qu'est-ce qu'on destine à
6 en bande dessinée
alors on recopie pas mal de trouver
mieux qu'on aime alors c'est quoi
justement alors c'était pas des jeux
tromso peut être du voile à des trucs
d'enfants toutes sortes qui luc tous les
classiques de la bd on passe par les
classiques puis après on le panel de
culturel evolution
j'ai à prendre le bus s'est retrouvé son
style après une si on recopie et c'est
quoi votre style comment vous le
définissez aujourd'hui c'est difficile
le mieux serait de regarder c'est comme
quand on demande à un groupe de musique
et les sons sitôt la lune elle c'est de
regarder et d'écouter je dirais comme ça
dans le pour définir mon style
techniquement on appelle ça du semi
réalisme donc dans la bd il yal'image
voilà dans la baie médias du il ya le
réalisme évidemment qui se rapproche de
la photo le semi réalisme qui est une
partie un petit peu plus stylisée mais
qui reste avec des proportions on va
dire classique
et puis il ya le ya l'aspect grenet en
bd alors là du coup c'est plutôt pour le
comique et là j'en suis loin quand même
une fois les études terminées c'est
plutôt le monde de la publicité pourtant
qui vous attire bah c'est surtout
histoire de gagner des sous à vivre de
la bande destinée s'est sabordé le teint
faut voilà faut faire ses armes et moi
après mes études je me suis dit tiens
qu'est-ce qui pourrait m'apporter un
petit peu d'argent en continuant à
dessiner et je suis parti dans cette
aventure là sachant que ce serait
vraiment ponctuel mais c'est
effectivement une rencontre après qui
vous permet de lancer votre première
série phénomène homme si c'était avec
jérémy qu'anne-k tout à fait 2002 pour
la date de première sortie cette
rencontre là c'est le lancement de série
ça va changer quelque chose pour vous
ben oui parce qu'en fait dès le début ça
qui est un très bon accueil sur cette
série est donc
en plus que ce sens mieux s'en porter
les gens adhèrent j'ai pas mal de monde
en dédicace au festival d'angoulême
catégorie meilleur premier album aussi
c'est ça exactement
et cette série-là est aujourd'hui
définitivement terminée alors on verra
la possibilité d'en faire une suite
ouais pas mal un moment même on était en
mèche avec des studios américains qui
voulaient l'adapter au cinéma
donc ça prend beaucoup de temps et puis
les années dans je ne sais plus trop où
ça en est mais en tout cas il y avait
quand même une petite touche à quelque
chose il ya moyen d'en faire un film en
tout cas je crois qu'il avait même le
besson qui était intéressant et vous
aimeriez d'une seulement des récents oui
après le milieu du cinéma est très
cloisonné et très rares sont les auteurs
de bd qui peuvent quand même mettre
leurs pattes après quand un film se
construit oui parce que vous parliez cg
il ya eu à l'expérience notamment qui
était pas forcément très bien accueillis
non plus par le public alors ça vous
l'avez apprécié votre la bd le film
après c'est vrai que c'est on vous voyez
une benne à transposer sur le grand
écran c'est le je dirais que c'est la
différence entre un bouquin est un film
certes on y met toujours un peu de soi
même et le film déjà comme tout est à
portée forcément moins valérian je
l'imaginé autrement mais après c'est
peut-être la vision qu'ils avaient des
sombres chacun a son chacun fait son
héros à travers la lecture même en bd ça
marche
cette mode peut-être en ce moment
d'adapter tous les héros de bouc de
bandes dessinées au cinéma vous trouvez
que c'est productif justement pour le
cinéma ça c'est en tout cas ça c'est pas
contre-productif complètement moi je
trouve que ça sert la bd déjà d'un d'une
part et on s'aperçoit que la bande
dessinée c'est un vivier créatif
absolument
phénoménal et en france on se rend pas
forcément compte où ça vient petit à
petit que c'est une exception culturelle
est assez peu de pays qui font de la
bande dessinée quand on réfléchit bien
il ya la france et la belgique
évidemment en europe après un petit peu
dit l'insee reste vraiment anecdotique
l'angleterre l'espagne en allemagne pas
grand chose il ya les etats-unis le
japon évidemment et en fait il ya quatre
grandes nations du la bande dessinée on
en fait partie et c'est bien de la
choyer un petit peu et c'est très
créatif et ça m'étonne pas que ce soit
vraiment un vivier pour justement donner
des idées de scénario même si
quelquefois le résultat est pas toujours
à la hauteur c'est ça c'est comme quand
on adapte un roman des discussions dès
qu'ils sont passés après je laisse libre
vous arriverez sur plusieurs titres dont
island iasi dargaud vous n'êtes pas
focaliser sur un seul héros vous n'avez
pas envie de vous lancer sur une sur une
saga personnage à la tintin astérix
je n'ai sûrement pas encore trouvé après
je trouve que la bande dessinée évolue
quand même
et maintenant c'est vrai qu'on se dirige
beaucoup plus sur des séries courtes les
anciennes séries tome 22 23 27 c'est
vrai que c'est plus tellement tendance
les gens veulent des soies des diptyques
ont des séries 2 des triptyques et puis
après si si ça marche et que ça remporté
un succès on peut faire une suite mais
c'est vraiment différent les gens les
gens voient là veulent plus acheter
voilà vingt à trente albums savent où
trouver l'inspiration à chaque fois pour
vous relancer dans une bande dessinée on
viendra après sur votre méthode de
travail mais on fait un petit peu des
enquêtes un petit peu d'historiens pour
sa part exactement alors s'est il n'y a
pas de méthode type ça peut être une
rencontre ça peut être un sujet qu'on
voit à la télé ça peut être une émission
radio ça peut être un bouquin et puis
d'un second éditeur et bâtir ça c'est un
sujet ça c'est le sujet que j'ai envie
de traiter et il se trouve que avant
donc avant
islande il a pris le temps d'y à j'ai
traité du fbi alors là c'était vraiment
un gros gros travail de recherche sur
hoover et là j'ai essayé de trouver
vraiment des documents qu'ils soient pas
tellement connu sur sa vie beaucoup de
trucs en anglais donc des fois j'ai
l'impression de soi des 30es chose est
d'être un journaliste justement vous
avez travaillé aussi sur les forces
spéciales vous avez cette volonté de
réalisme comment ce travail-là se passe
comment vous prenez contact attache
auprès des forces spéciales c'est
particulier il trouve que c'est des
percées c'est eux qui sont venus à moi
parce que effectivement à côté de
versailles
ils ont leurs bases ils avaient leurs
bases à villacoublay et il se trouve que
une des personnes qui travaillent avec
eux qui s'appelle le sac de l'arbalète
et qui est amené à travailler avec les
entreprises pour développer les
nouvelles technologies au service des
forces spéciales m'a demandé de
travailler pour lui pour les 25 ans de
la création du cos le coz qui est le
commandant des opérations spéciales
ce premier album est né à l'occasion des
25 ans de leur création et donc au
départ je connaissais rien est ce qu'il
faut dire c'est qu'avec l'armée au
départ quand on connaît rien il faut un
petit temps d'adaptation parce qu'ils
parlent tous en a hand et abréger les
agressions du tourisme avec rdp
rpm a donc rhp gosses on y qu'on n'y
comprend rien on fait semblant de se
dire oui oui tout à fait et puis petit à
petit on regarde ce que c'est et puis on
va là on s'améliore il ya cette volonté
de réalisme vous signez quelquefois les
scénarios quelquefois les dessins des
fois les deux vous préférez quoi
j'aime bien tout faire alors c'est assez
mais parce qu'en fait j'ai apprécié
match et sont plutôt solitaire au
général après je suis pas focalisé pour
être vraiment seul tout le temps je
trouve que c'est bien aussi des fois
d'apporter un petit quelque chose de
nouveau en collaboration mais j'aime
bien ça que j'aime bien écrire en tout
cas collaboré à l'écriture et je trouve
qu'il ya une cohérence quand le l'auteur
est complet c'est ce qu'on dit dans le
jargon de la bande dessinée auteur
complet scénaristes ou dessinateurs donc
l'auteur complet celui qui fait dessin
et scénario est donc vous restez quand
vous travaillez même si vous signez
scénario et dessin vous échangez quand
même vous montrer ses dessins à d'autres
dessinateurs
oui oui bien sûr alors chaque
dessinateur gras garde vraiment après un
peu moins mais c'est vrai que quand on
démarre c'est intéressant justement de
se confronter aux autres on est toujours
le bon dessinateur de papa maman ou de
ses copains mais c'est pas la réalité du
doigt dire du du milieu après c'est
intéressant d'aller voir ce que font les
autres d'avoir des critiques des autres
des critiques des pros quand on veut
démarrer et là on est là on progresse
vraiment parce que je trouve que
effectivement il ya un très très bon
niveau de dessin en france info les des
auteurs française pour moi sont vraiment
très très bon et des dessinateurs des
auteurs vous allez rencontrer un certain
nombre lors du festival de la bande
dessinée de but qu'au début du mois
d'octobre c'est un moment particulier ce
moment de rencontre avec les autres
auteurs et puis avec le public aussi
également bien sûr alors nous on est
habitués en tant qu auteur de bande
dessinée a travaillé son atelier à deux
ou trois où seul
moi j'aime bien travailler seule voie la
plus solitaire finalement et donc avec
tous ces festivals permettent de se
rencontrer c'est un petit milieu la
bande dessinée donc on a toujours des
personnes qu'on connaît avec qui on a
des affinités donc c'est un moment
d'échangé justement de 2
et de se retrouver enfin c'est très
intéressant
le public évidemment l'intérêt c'est
d'avoir la réaction sur son travail et
ça c'est précieux voilà vous avez
travaillé en amont de ce festival avec
des publics incarcéré en prison exact
bois d'arcy à poissy auprès de jeunes
comment se passent ces séances avec le
comment vous appréhendez le dessin avec
eux alors
commenge apprend le dessin avec lui se
trouve que bon c'est des personnes qui
disait assez peu de bd
voilà il connaissait les classiques
tintin astérix lucky luke est appréhendé
le dessin d'abord c'est des petits coups
je donne des petits cours de dessin donc
là en expliquant quels sont les
différents styles de bd leur donnant
vraiment des bases et après en essayant
leur donner confiance en deux en dix ans
même si on se tutoyait en prison même si
tu n'arrives pas à dessiner la bande
dessinée on peut s'exprimer mais avec un
bonhomme bâton un rond des traits et en
fait ça part de là peu importe
et puis prennent confiance et petit à
petit en les corrigeant en leur montrant
en leur disant que la bd on ne part pas
tout de suite sur une planche ont fait
des dessins côté on essaie de trouver
son personnage
donc il dessine il a dit il à présent
beaucoup mieux le la page blanche un peu
comme un auteur et puis petit à petit
voilà on réussit à leur retirer quelque
chose qui ressemble à la bande dessinée
il était même eux mêmes surpris du
résultat
donc là c'était moi pour moi la plus
grande gratification vous avez réalisé
un calendrier aussi c'est ça en
collaboration avec la mairie de buc gym
avec constance qui m'avait contacté à
cette occasion là qui cherchent à un
auteur dont je trouve que comme suit je
suis locale ils ont pensé à moi et que
je pense qu'ils sont contents du
résultat donc avec une autre collègue
qui reste avec des prix gel c'est un ami
qui elle s'occupait de la prison des
femmes et moi j'étais à poissy à bois
d'arcy et cette expérience l'a été
particulièrement enrichissantes pour
vous justement ce seuil est un peu le
complètement parce que effectivement
assez poussée c'est un milieu jusque là
dans lequel je n'avais jamais pénétrer
mais là c'était pour une bonne raison
parfois plus simple et la plus simpliste
alors là ça c'est la prison des deux
faces
de versailles et donc il ya des planches
qui ressemble quand même un peu plus à
de la bande dessinée qu'est-ce que je
travaillerai pour l'expérience qu'elles
seront pour conclure vos projets une
fois ce festival de but passé vous
travaillez sur quoi actuellement on
travaille sur le tome 2 des forces
spéciales justement alors là c'est c'est
encore une autre histoire le premier
raconter l'histoire de la création du
commandement des opérations spéciales
justement suite à la première guerre du
golfe en 91
ils ont ils sont créés en 92 et là je
travaille sur l'après guerre de bosnie
herzégovine au moment où la france doit
rechercher les criminels de guerre et
c'est une liste qui avait été donné par
le tribunal international de la haye et
donc la france s'était engagée à
rechercher des criminels de guerre
il a sûrement il ya un commando des
forces spéciales qui va chercher un des
types qui recherchait mais on oublie
parfois la bande dessinée c'est aussi un
bon moyen de découvrir l'histoire ce
n'est pas uniquement un moyen de même si
c'est important mais de rire de sourire
il ya aussi toute cette visée
pédagogique historique derrière la bande
dessinée bien souvent avec cette
richesse qu'on a en france notamment
merci beaucoup marqué c est revenue vous
êtes présent à buc lors du festival de
la bande dessinée 6 et 7 octobre
on se retrouve pardon bientôt pour une
prochaine rencontre avec une
personnalité yvelinoise
[Musique]